Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie, happy early Christmas
new Spider-Man trailer with different footage
from the last month so let's break it down
there is another round of the Spider-Man giveaway
that starting now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Make sure you click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything.
So the second trailer is way more hard-core
than that, first trailer focuses more on the
action less on Peter Parker as a high school
character more on the Spider-Man part of the
movie but you have a couple different things
going on here.
You have Peter Parker in high school and you
have him trying to become an avenger through
the course of the film learning to be a better
Spider-Man so funny His line this trailer
hands down is him dropping Peter back off
in his neighborhood after Civil War like the
kind of a nice continuity with the way they
start to trailer at the airport battle scene
where he says that you can keep the suit,
but if you think this makes you an avenger.
It does not not hugging you just get in the
door for yet good like kid this pushes him
on his way.
So it gives you a lot more context to how
he fits into the avengers because I think
technically he's an avenger, but the whole
reason that Tony Stark keeps treating him
like a kid which is why gets really upset
later in the trailer is because he wants Peter
to have the childhood that he never got to
have like his parents were killed, so he had
to grow up really fast and we all saw the
montage in that first Iron Man film like he
had all these awards he was this child prodigy,
but he had a problem with women he had a problem
with alcohol.
He had a problem which is kind of checking
out in general like he was completely checked
out from reality before he went into that
cave in the first Iron Man film so it seems
like he really wants Peter to have a normal
childhood like he does want to get hurt is
not the he doesn't want Peter to be an avenger.
So the other big thing about this footage
is that it teases the villain team up with
the shocker in the Tinker in a couple other
people, so that the shockers really the biggest
thing that is a much better look at his character
so it seems like the Tinker is the one who's
building all the tech for like the shocker
for the vulture his flight suit.
So even though Michael Keaton is going to
be the big bad of the film the vultures like
the big main villain.
You go for like a really small team up to
evolve villain team up by the end of the film
the world is changing, it's time we change
with it.
So, that's also happening on the Spider-Man
side of things.
Spider-Man is changing time for him to evolve
into a much more fully fledged hero.
So you just have to remember that this is
the first film, he's only a sophomore high
school, so he's about 16 years old.
So even though he complains that Tony Stark
treats him like a kid.
He really is still a kid we can start laying
bets on how long it's gonna take Tony Stark
to officially acknowledge him as an avenger
is gonna take to the third.
Spider-Man homecoming bill is a can happen
at the end of this film.
The other thing they have going on in the
background here is a lot of miles morale of
stuff from the comics so his best friend Genki
knows his identity, so that's kind of what
they're doing with the net leads character
here and then people talk a lot about how
this is like a Jon Hughes high school film
that's what's going on with all this Liz Allan
stuff in the Michelle stuff, so it seems like
he has this super hard on for Liz Allan who
is a really important character if you read
the comics she ends up getting married to
Harry Osborn in the future they have a son
together member Harry Osborn, the son of Norman
Osborne future Green goblin, so no idea if
there ever can address that of the movie.
Probably not, because at the end of this trilogy
to all be about 18 years old.
So Peter really likes Liz Allan, but the thing
about Jon Hughes films is it's usually about
not seeing the thing that's right in front
of you because you're too caught up with your
own bowl should so look to the side and who
is this person here who Peter just barely
recognizes so that is the person he's probably
going to end up with at the end of the film
because they did all that promotional stuff
with Zen Deya like how many interviews have
you seen Tom Holland do with this Liz Allan
character all of his interviews have been
with Zen Deya so very clearly she's gonna
be a huge character in the film with the way
they sell it in this trailer is that Peter's
all about Liz Allan, so something can happen
during the film and he's going to see the
thing is been in front of him this whole time.
So speaking of things being in front of him
the whole time at the front of this class
up on the board here you see a picture of
Bruce Banner now because all these pictures
look like great people in the history of the
world in the history of science the reason
he's on there probably has something to do
with his research into gamma like there's
always lots of gamma jokes that they stick
into things like the joke at the beginning
of the first avengers film were Doctor Selvig
like we don't know what's going on with the
Tesseract it's giving off all this gamma energy
and should be okay and then Nick fury cocks
his eyebrow and is like I've seen gamma do
some really terrible stuff before and everybody
knows that he's talking about the hold.
So you Peter Parker stuck in high school with
the Iron Man voiceover look, kid, I know high
school sucks.
I know you want to be an avenger you want
to be hero that you're not ready yet.
So throughout the course of the film, he's
going to be stuck in this really mundane life
dreaming about being it avenger.
So along comes the Fulcher all these of the
big villains provides him the opportunity
to try and prove himself this is my chance
to prove myself.
That was one of the other most important lines
in the trailer and looks like it happens the
Washington Monument where it seems like is
like the first big vulture attack.
So there's any question.
This is the Tinker and we don't know exactly
who Donald Glover is playing a current best
guess is that he's the prowler and I know
a lot of your wondering it's totally possible
that the shocker is the person that's robbing
this ATM just because of the gear that he's
using.
So they could come back later when they team
up with the vulture, everybody evolving the
world's changing time we changed with it so
that the shocker gets like super awesome gear
by the end of the film just like the other
villains just like Spider-Man getting cool
gear by the end of the film to, but let me
know which of these trailers you like more.
The first one or this one here think most
people actually like the international version
of the trailer better just because it hypes
the action little bit more.
But what can happen is is I will do a Spider-Man
Q&A this weekend leave all your questions
about the movie about anything you want me
to include in that later today I'll post my
legends of tomorrow finale video and then
you have like a ghost writer agents of shield
video that will also try to get out this weekend
to lots more comic book stuff happening this
weekend is gonna be really fun what you guys
wait for that to post you can click here to
watch that other Spider-Man trailer to compare
the footage and you can click here to rewatch
the guardians of the Galaxy trailer.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!